Hello, and welcome to today's Unreal Engine training on setting up for scalability.
So today we'll talk about interface systems and parent child classes.
So what does that cover?
Object orientated concepts, we'll discuss how we approach these in Unreal Engine.
We'll talk about the difference between controller and pawn classes.
We'll talk about working with blueprint interfaces, which is essentially just a messaging
system inside of Unreal Engine from one blueprint to another.
And then we'll talk about creating a basic light switch that turns on and off to give
you an idea of how to use these concepts.
So let's get started.